Ok so you’re really excited about Rogue One,
but when you watch the trailer you only recognize Darth Vader and this lady whose weird name you can’t remember.
It’s Mon Mothma
Here’s the rundown on the characters you don’t know yet.
Caution. The spoilers are strong with this one.
Jyn Erso was born in captivity while her parents were prisoners of the Separatist Army,
they are freed for a bit, but then captured again when she is 15 years old.
As a result she becomes a criminal badass.
Like other Star Wars protagonists,
Jyn’s daddy issues get her recruited by the rebel alliance,
Galen Erso is Jyn’s father and also, kinda the Elon Musk of the Star Wars Universe,
but instead of Electric Cars, his scientific specialty is kyber crystals
Kyber crystals can be used to magnify energy and are basically the engine in lightsabers.
The Empire captures Galen because they want to use his expertise
to make something a little bigger, than a lightsaber.
Galen Erso: "Say you understand."
Jyn Erso: "I understand."
Orson Krennic is the Director of Advanced Weapons Research
tasked with creating the Death Star’s Superlaser,
nd he needs help if he is going to get promoted to a rank people don’t question
second adult man wearing a cape on the same space station.
Orson and Galen went to school together
and Orson uses that connection to manipulate Galen,
into taking a position researching Kyber crystal as a “renewable energy source,”
What is it renewing?
which, unbeknownst to Galen, is actually powering a giant planet killing laser.
Saw Gerrera is the one that flies the Erso family to safety from Krennic all those years ago,
and Jyn still sees him as a friend.
Saw is the leader of a resistance group on Jedha known as the Partisans,
who become one of the first cells to join the rebel alliance.
During the Clone Wars, he was subjected to torture,
which may explain his … poor footing.
Saw Gerrera: "The world is coming undone."
Ok I don't think that joke was that bad.
Joinging Jyn on her mission is Captain Cassian Andor.
He’s an Intelligence Officer in the Alliance to Restore the Republic.
Cassian is more on the practical side to Jyn’s radical.
He recruits for the rebels and apparently deletes the memory of Imperial droids in his free time,
which I consider to be a handy hobby.
Cassian Andor: "Good"
Take C3P0s lack of a social filter and love of statistics,
and mix in Chewbaca's ability to rip peoples arms off, and you've got K-2S0
Originally created to fight in the Galactic Empire’s armed forces,
this Imperial Enforcer droid provides protection and some comic relief.
K-2SO- " I will not kill you."
Chirrut Imwe is a blind, staff wielding, warrior monk.
He was born on Jedha, the ancient home of the Jedi religion
and although he isn’t force sensitive himself he is fiercely devoted to its principles.
As we’ve seen fighting blind is hard even for people that have a high midichlorian count,
but I would say this guy’s only disability is that he is a bit too brave.
Chirrut Îmwe- "All is as the Force wills it."
Baze Malbus is Chirrut’s BFF with a BFG.
Like his bestie he grew up on Jedha, but Baze isn’t the spiritual type.
He’s a freelance assassin with a trademark Heavy repeater cannon
and he’s pretty good with other weapons too.
He is a dude who kills people for a living
and something the Empire did has gotten him pretty pissed off.
wonder what that could be...
Baze Malbus- "They destroyed our home!"
Bodhi Rook is the pilot of Rogue One and he has a lot in common with many of his teammates.
Like Baze and Chirrut, he is from Jedha,
like Jyn he is a little hot headed,
and like K2SO he used work for the empire.
He was an imperial cargo pilot which isn’t quite glamorous, (It's kinda like a truck driver)
but he’s got his radio communication game down.
Bodhi Rook- "Rogue."
Some other character honorable mentions are Rebel Admiral Raddus,
Generals Draven and  Merrick,
Partisan soldiers Edrio and Benthic Two tubes (Brothers),
Gigoran Mercenary Moroff,
Rebel soldier Pao,
and U wing door gunner, Bistan the freaking space monkey.
This movie is going to be amazing.
For more on your favorite comic books, TV shows and movies, check out gamespot universe.